oh
la surprise du jour en pologne
solidarité pourrait être reconnue
officiellement le premier ministre
polonais des finances époux union défaut
cet appareil avait un système
d'extinction l'inversé ils ont été
contrôlés
après la catastrophe de l'iphone
aucune nouvelle de paul vanden boeynants
plusieurs revendications doute de
l'enlèvement de l'ancien premier
ministre
la perte est chine et rebondit il y
avait bien des initiés essentiellement
des financiers du proche orient
c'est le journal le monde qu'il affirme
la guerre de la pêche à l'autre bout du
monde
saint malo entre saint pierre et
miquelon on joue les arrêts de jeu
bonsoir et avant de développer tous ces
titres une nouvelle très triste qui sera
aussi un hommage la mère denis est morte
c'était sans doute la grand mère la plus
célèbre de france et elle était devenue
star sur le tard à 79 ans seulement elle
fait éteinte dans sa 95e année maire de
boé ni eux ni nous avoir montré sa merci
mais vous l'avez quand même congédié la
mère denis l'authenticité la solidité
toutes ces images comme vous dites
qu'elle était censée incarner tout cela
c'est passé de mode
aujourd'hui on ne bat ouïe plus le linge
comme disait la dame
le microprocesseur a chassé le battoir
et tant pis pour la mère de lou et vous
ressemblez pourtant bien un peu
mademoiselle jeanne le calvez et marié
denis employés hochmann ferrand 44 puis
sans réserve elle lavait le linge de la
commune à barneville-carteret calvados
et voilà son voisin était un ingénieur
commercial et à 80 ans l'inconnu de
vingt stars et même auteur d'un livre
ce qu'on n'a pas fait avec vous mais
redoux vraiment oui c'est ça depuis huit
ans il vivait dans un presbytère
ça leur de stars noms de vedettes elle
s'était acheté ce lieu où on n'a plus
grand chose à laver
chaque jour où ben oui
quant à eux je bois pas je bosse la
surprise des interrogations apple à une
syndicat solidarité pourrait être
reconnue officiellement
le premier ministre monsieur rakowski se
prononcer pour le principe dans le futur
solidarité serez reconnu mais sous
certaines conditions
à l'ère du côté de solidarnosc on se
montre un petit peu sceptique
jean-marc il use le cheval hézard
deviendra t-il bientôt et le plus
légalement du monde le président de
solidarité
le mouvement syndical polonais interdit
depuis sept ans déjà
c'est l'ange officielle des 48 heures de
débats qui s'achève ce soir devant le
comité central du parti communiste
polonais cet après midi pour la première
force
nietzsche et cela fera qu'au ski le plus
modéré des premiers ministres polonais
depuis bien longtemps s'est clairement
prononcé pour une reconnaissance de
solidarité pas tout de suite et sous
conditions mais une reconnaissance qu'il
refusait encore il ya quelques semaines
si elle triomphe d opposition
conservatrice dans le parti dans le
syndicat officiel et dans l'appareil de
sécurité
la proposition raccord ce qui
permettrait la légalisation solidarité
pendant une période d'essai de deux ans
mais cheval et ça pourrait alors
peut-être accepter la négociation qu'il
avait refusé au gouvernement lors de son
spectaculaire face à face télévisé de
novembre avec les syndicats officiels et
s'engager comme monsieur rakowski le lui
demandent a renoncé à la grève pendant
ces deux années
d'où la deuxième inconnue leur walesa
acceptera-t-il comme le lui suggère
aujourd'hui le pouvoir polonais de ne
plus être un nous plongeons mais un
partenaire
abbas au soir la discussion est serré en
attendant le vote du comité central les
proches de solidarité retiennent leur
souffle
plusieurs tentatives de rapprochement
entre le pouvoir et sa principale
opposition ont déjà capoté
ces derniers mois les burning était mal
branchés sept d'entre eux tout au moins
c'est ce qu'ont découvert avec stupeur
les ingénieurs chargés de contrôler tous
les appareils ou après la catastrophe de
leicester ou un 747 de la british
midland s'était écrasé en faisant 44
morts
c'est peut-être là la cause de la
catastrophe patrick esther il s'en passe
de belles chez boeing est un secteur
plus les ingénieurs gélifie d'avion et
plus ils s'aperçoivent que les erreurs
de montage électrique sont nombreuses
sur les appareils âgés de moins d'un an
sur les boeing 737 et 757 contrôlé
depuis vendredi dernier
elle présentait un grave défaut les
câbles je suis une alarme incendie
étaient inversés l'administration
américaine a ordonné que tous les
modèles de ceux construits soeur
subissent une vérification s'est
découverte conforte l'une des hypothèse
selon laquelle le boeing 737 400 se sont
écrasés en angleterre à la suite d'une
erreur de signalisation de bord le
moteur de gauche en se chauffant aurait
déclenché une alarme correspondant aux
moteurs de droite le pilote aurait alors
coupé le moteur de droite
l'avion poursuivant son vol durant plus
de vingt minutes sur le moteur en
surchauffe
al'approche de l'atterrissage le pilote
en remettant les gaz à fond aurait
provoqué l'explosion du moteur
toutefois les pannes des sept derniers
boeing concerné non pas la version d
alarme incendie des moteurs mais des
soutes à bagages à seattle les
responsables de la firme américaine vont
maintenant devoir trouver l'origine de
ces erreurs
la disparition de vdb en belgique
l'ancien premier ministre n'a toujours
pas été retrouvé malgré les recherches
de la police depuis hier soir il y avait
plusieurs revendications d'un éventuel
enlèvement mais elle semble bien
suspecte il a milli a même une
revendication très douteuse au monde
action directe alors le point sur les
enquêtes tout de suite à bruxelles avec
isabelle bechler c'est la guerre des
revendications depuis zias toi rouent de
coups téléphone identique à nos
s'étonnant de la brigade socialiste
révolutionnaire qu'on ne retrouverait le
corps de paul vanden boeynants quand
petit morceau one macabre mais
totalement contradictoire
également signé bss une lettre et un
revenu ce matin dans deux rédactions
bruxelloise dans celle du soir
il s'agit dans cette lettre d'un char a
bien marxisant qui réclament une rançon
de 30 millions de francs belges de 5
millions de francs français pour je cite
soulager la pauvreté en belgique au nom
des travailleurs une lettre qui semble
bien un peu fantaisiste mais les
enquêteurs s'attachent au moindre indice
la dernière manifestation en date cet
après-midi de prétendus ravisseurs et
man ray décès c'est le groupe terroriste
des cellules communistes combattantes là
le correspondant téléphonique a donné un
ultimatum de 72 heures et propose de
laisser la vie à l'ancien premier
ministre belge contre la libération des
quatre membres des ccc qui ont été
condamnés à de très lourdes peines de
prison en octobre dernier les affaires
suite mais pas fin loin de là
aujourd'hui le journal le monde publie
une longue enquête à propos de la sphère
pechiney une enquête où apparaît une
piste libanaise
la coop la cob la commission des
opérations en bourse enquêterait en
effet sur des financiers du moyen-orient
ce sont eux qui a laissé les plus gros
bénéfices les plus gros profits dans la
sphère au moment du rachat par péchiney
d'une société américaine
deux noms ressortent de l'enquète du
monde sur le samir traboulsi et celui de
roger tamraz éclaircissements véronique
auger et 15 16 et 17 novembre dernier
deux cent vingt mille actions croyant
gueule la société-mère d'american kahn
sont achetées à la bourse de new york
alors qu'il s'en est changée
traditionnellement deux à trois mille
chaque jour là est ce ici le gendarme de
la bourse américaine
flers le délit d'initié un délit qui
auraient été commis à l'occasion du
rachat d'american khan le numéro un
mondial de l'emballage par péchiney un
rachat annoncée officiellement par jean
gandois le lundi 21 novembre avec l'aide
de la cob l'aes ici en quête des noms
sortent on parle d'abord de max père est
l'ancien patron de la fnac qui auraient
acheté 32300 actions mais aussi de roger
patrice pelât un ami du chef de l'état
qui aurait acquis dix mille titres et
puis de certaines charges parisienne au
total plus de cinquante mille actions
achetées de france
mais la sec s'intéresse également à la
suisse est un intermédiaire
luxembourgeois petrus ces deux là selon
le journal le monde que les enquêteurs
américains auraient retrouvé la piste
des 168 milles autres titres délictueux
cette piste les mène au proche orient
avec surtout la présence d'un financier
libanais roger tamraz président jusqu'à
il ya une semaine à peine de la banque
de participation et de placement mais
dans le directeur général nie toute
participation à la faire
la première remarque c'est que la vente
de participations placement de liens je
vais dit quelques la société et tous
comme sommes comparé actionnaires de
cette société
qui concerne les opérations entre été
fait avec la société et tous nous
n'avons fait aucune opération avec elle
il m'a fallu l'appellation avec pour le
moment la cob ne fait aucun commentaire
mais s'intéresserait aussi selon
certains au rôle d'un autre financier
libanais samir traboulsi l'homme mais
pas avoir de signes extérieurs de
richesse voitures de luxe yachts
appartement multiples il est
milliardaire pas avoir non plus de
prodigalité et services rendus à
l'ensemble de la classe politique à
gauche comme à droite
précieux monsieur traboulsi qui ce soir
dément toute relation avec roger tamraz
ce dans le cadre d'une affaire pechiney
la dernière fois que j'ai vu 3 je sais
pas responsable jusqu'au fond trouvent
ils allaient dans le monde et je trouve
normal qu'un m'a complètement sans elle
je n'ai pas une seule action en triangle
pas un seul et ça la vérité éclater un
jour ou l'autre on se rappelait pas les
seules actions
r ce qu'ils ont et ses actions l'ont
fait à mon insu et ont mis en cause est
en danger là pour laquelle je
travaillais il faut pas être très malin
pour le comprendre
on sait que traboulsi négocier dès la mi
juillet pour le compte du président
américain ou trilingues ans nelson peltz
avec les représentants de pechiney mais
aussi avec alain boublil le directeur de
cabinet de bérégovoy un proche de
traboules si la question se pose alors
qui a informé les investisseurs proche
orientaux et leur a permis de réaliser
de très confortables plus values
les coupables sont ils proches du
pouvoir ce n'est que lorsque l'accord
bord a répondu à cette question qu'elle
pourra saisir les tribunaux les
modérations dans la hausse des loyers un
texte vient de paraître en ce sens au
journal officiel alors si votre loyer
augmente de plus de 10% la lauze devra
être étalés sur six ans cette mesure
s'applique pour tous les comptes rend sa
nouvelle à partir du 14 janvier
89 la guerre saint malo saint camille
claus est une guerre de la pêche les
habitants de ce département français
perdus dans les glaces près du groënland
les saint pierrais
donc ne veulent pas voir les bateaux
malouin venir pêcher dans leur zone tout
l'archipel est en effervescence
moi aussi et la situation est bloquée
christophe martet la grande hermine
c'est l'arrivée de cet énorme chalutiers
usine de saint malo qui a provoqué la
colère des saint pierrais ils
n'admettent pas que ce navire vienne
ratisser une zone de pêche qu'ils jugent
trop exigus ces français du bout du
monde ont déjà dû céder une partie de
leurs zones de pêche aux canadiens
aujourd'hui il doit partager ce qu'il
reste avec des pêcheurs métropolitain
les deux navires de saint malo nous
équiper sont selon eux une menace pour
l'économie de leur île entièrement
tournée vers la mer pour tenter de
mettre fin à la tension qui règne sur
l'île
le gouvernement a exigé que la grande
hermine 16 provisoirement toute activité
ce qui devrait permettre aux
négociations de reprendre les îles
locaux sont maintenant attendus à paris
pour une rencontre de la dernière chance
avec le premier ministre avec moi
adacore à paris pour les municipales
entre socialistes et communistes ce
matin les négociations ont tourné court
le ps ait réclamé la tête de liste d'un
deux arrondissements réponse négative du
ps et après pour des municipales une
réflexion sur la place que les français
originaires du maghreb doivent tenir sur
la liste l'association france puce prévu
que croise un jeune beur pourraient être
élus sur des listes municipales à droite
comme à gauche au parti socialiste pour
la première fois il existe un délégué
chargé des français originaires du
maghreb
pascal guimier le vote beurre personne
ne sait s'il existe vraiment mais les
politiques prennent leurs précautions
on ne sait jamais l'enjeu près d'un
million de français d'origine maghrébine
pour la moitié inscrits sur les listes
électorales cartes d'identité et cartes
d'électeurs en poche des français
pas tout à fait comme les autres tout
simplement parce que particulièrement
content qu'ils aient à
municipal à droite comme à gauche les
partis font assaut de politesse pour
qu'il figure sur leur lit le ps lui
semble bien avoir pris une petite
longueur d'avancé
l'objectif en tout cas est clair
l'intégration par la politique
un programme ambitieux mais sans doute
pas tout à fait désintéressée donne pas
des plages crois qu'ils les ont ils ont
conquise et je crois que c'est un
phénomène tout à fait naturel il est
normal ça il faut que ça devienne banal
maintenant que à toutes les élections il
y ait entre autres des candidats
d'origine maghrébine les beurs disent
banco
mais sans être dupe des arrière pensées
qui pourrait peut-être se cacher
derrière le paravent des bonnes
intentions se présenter aux municipales
rien de plus normal
à condition de ne pas y faire que de la
figuration l'essentiel c'est le résultat
si le résultat c'est que c est lui
permettent de faire régresser le racisme
est d'améliorer la situation des
communautés immigrées dans telle rue par
exemple ou pour l'aménagement de telles
grandes cités le bilan sera très positif
à roubaix grenoble toulouse bordeaux à
rouen pour flanc ou bien dunkerque aussi
bien sur des listes de droite que sur
des listes de gauche près de 300 morts
seront en position d'être élu en mars
prochain
seule partie ce soir apporté un bémol le
front national s'il s'agit de français
qui entendent défendre les intérêts de
la france nous n'avons rien contre ce
qui nous paraît grave par contre c'est
de commencer à faire une comptabilité de
l'origine ethnique ou religieuse des
candidats sur les listes électorales car
il s'agirait là de discriminations
raciales ethniques religieuses qui sont
radicalement contraire aux principes de
la constitution française ça nous
rejetons totalement un front national
qui lui a toujours soigné ses amis a
requis en matière d'élection c'est bien
connu
chaque voix compte et comptera 2
non plus l'académie de paris un nouveau
recteur il s'agit de madame michel
gendre massa lourds qui vient de la
seine fermés qui avait été précédemment
conseiller à l'elysée madame joindre ma
salle où prend place madame harvey l'air
au conseil des ministres ce matin on a
beaucoup parlé d'éducation confirmation
des crédits débloqués pour ce secteur
décisif
et puis cet après midi début de la
concertation entre lionel jospin le
ministre et toutes les parties prenantes
en fait une concertation qui va durer
plusieurs mois
jusqu'à la loi d'orientation qui elle
pourrait être votée au printemps
chantal kimmerlin et dominique leriche
suivre les discussions au ministère de
l'éducation
la syrie devait résumer phrase du captif
de lionel jospin ce serait plus est un
jeune nous devrons sortir de l'école
sans diplôme
le ministre a présenté la loi
d'orientation pour l'éducation de
vendredi l'organisation représentant les
allemands les enseignants les parents
d'élèves nous sommes les élus locaux et
le patronat à mettre en exergue grand
objectif qui devrait être atteint dans
la décennie
le redoublement seconde exceptionnel le
rythme scolaire réétudier les exams à
simplifier nous essayons de vous remplir
un rôle éducatif ont marqué selon la
formule de lionel jospin
le principal changement concerne le
collège accueille deux professeurs de
collège sera créé la formation leur
statut leur père pierre seron analogue
professeur de lycée exigences pour la
pédagogie et 12 ans pour les acteurs de
l'éducation tels ceux des films et
projets aux tout petits du gouvernement
dans sa philosophie
si la plupart des représentants semblent
tout avis favorable au projet il semble
plus réservé sur les moyens qui seront
débloqués
pour l'instant je dois dire que si les
orientations de semble bonne
répondre à nombre de nos questions se
posent la question de savoir si on aura
les moyens du gouvernement a les moyens
de mettre un même réellement et aux
objectifs
là dessus nous sommes très interrogatif
la partir du moment les objectifs sont
indiqué qu'ils sont déclarés utile dans
l'intérêt des jeunes et du pays
il faut absolument que
que
la nation trouve les moyens de financer
pour atteindre ses objectifs qantas ne
semble pas une surcouche ou lara gut
allemands contre les enseignants dispute
en ce moment de ces propositions
puisqu'ils peuvent les suivre en direct
les premiers échos qui nous parviennent
c'est un fort mécontentement et la
volonté de ne pas laisser passer ces
mauvais choix
demain les négociations sur la
revalorisation des salaires des
enseignants une confrontation avec les
syndicats qui s'annonce encore plus
debout cat
le conseil constitutionnel vient de dire
oui mais au projet de loi sur le csa le
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel
ils estiment la loi conforme à deux
articles près deux dispositions mineures
que le conseil constitutionnel annule
donc mais cela ne devrait pas empêcher
le gouvernement de promulguer la loi de
la semaine prochaine les etats unis tel
qu'on ne les voit qu'au cinéma
d'habitude car c'est vrai dans la
réalité lorsqu'on voyage outre
atlantique on a plutôt l'impression d'un
pays un ordre et il faut les feuilletons
ou les films pour nous a donné une autre
image comme maya nivalis par exemple eh
bien ce qui s'est passé la nuit dernière
à miami justement donne une image et les
voir bien différente de l'amérique
dominique verdeilhan envers tone le
quartier le plus pauvre de miami jets de
pierres et de bouteilles mais aussi
coûteux voitures incendiées et magasins
pillés
tout un quartier habité en grande
majorité par une population noire a
affronté durant plus de cinq heures
les flics de miami les troubles ont
débuté en fin d'après midi les policiers
prennent en chasse une moto sur laquelle
s'enfuit deux jeunes gens soupçonnés de
vol un policier tire la moto entre en
collision avec une voiture
un des deux suspects est mort sur le
coup l'autre est blessé grièvement
plusieurs habitants du quartier une
centaine prennent alors le parti du
motocycliste durant plusieurs heures
plus de 1000 policiers s'affronteront
violemment avec les habitants de ce
quartier qui dans le passé fut déjà le
théâtre d'émeutes raciales
il y a neuf ans 18 personnes avaient été
tuées à la suite d'affrontements encore
plus violent l'état d'urgence n'a pas
été déclaré karl émeutes a été contenue
déclaré ce matin le maire de miami
bilan de cette nuit un mort et une
dizaine de blessés
aujourd'hui le calme est revenu à miami
en apparence seulement
hier les états unis célèbrent
l'anniversaire de la naissance de martin
luther king
le gouvernement allemand en mauvaise
posture à la sphère de lusine libyenne
de rapt à lui revient en pleine figure
le gouvernement donne a dû reconnaître
que losing libyenne était bien une
fabrique d'armes chimiques et dans le
même temps certaines sociétés allemandes
ont avoué avoir travaillé pour cette
usine
bernard benyamin on le pressentait
depuis plusieurs jours
la confirmation est arrivée hier soir
par la bouche du ministre ouest allemand
des finances
nous devons admettre at-il dit que dans
les usines de rapt à il y à bien un
département susceptibles de produire des
gaz toxiques et il y as well as de
fortes chances pour que des firmes
allemandes soit impliqué dans cette
affaire en première ligne la société
hima on soupçonnait depuis le début
d'avoir fourni et la libye certains
éléments clés pour fabriquer des armes
chimiques
aujourd'hui le magazine stern affirmant
qu'elle aurait même vendu aux libyens
les plans de lusine du rapt a et ce
n'est pas tout de nouvelles firmes ouest
allemand dont la société merck ont
reconnu avoir elle aussi livré du
matériel ou libyen très exactement 19
tonnes de dichloroéthane avons le porte
parole de la compagnie qui précise c'est
un produit chimique à tout faire lui
puis en somme si le mécanisme de montage
de l'usiné semble aujourd'hui
parfaitement clair il reste à prouver
qu'elle fabrique bien des armes
chimiques mais pour le moment il faudra
se contenter de ses vues aériennes de
rapt a prise par le satellite français
spot la répression roumanie depuis
quatre mois nous nous inquiétions ando
du sort de deux ina cornea c'est une
professeur de français qui avait été
interviewé par notre magazine résistance
elle avait osé
à cette occasion critiqué le régime
dictatorial de ceausescu effectivement
mince éclatement elle a été mise au
secret et humilié son genre vient
d'arriver à paris il l'a vu il ya
quelques jours à peine écoutez son
témoignage
et qu'elle était en feu
c'est ma famille
donc d'un corner à et roumaine à 66 ans
elle vient de vivre quatre mois de
cauchemar coupé du monde
la raison elle a osé devant des caméras
critiqué le régime de nicolae ceausescu
ici un crime impardonnable contre celui
qui s'est lui même surnommé en toute
simplicité les génie des carpates en
roumanie
le conducteur suprême est partout pas un
seul journal télévisé son visage pas une
seule librairie sans ses livres dans ce
concert de louanges la spontanéité
douteuses
la voix de cornet a était insupportable
une interview quatre mois d'humiliation
de privation de liberté
un tarif à l'image de chercher ce qu
elle ait été frappé de manière beaucoup
plus importante que la première fois
parce qu'elle était giflé plusieurs fois
avec violence et puis à la fin de
l'interrogatoire le policier l'insulté
et il lui a donné un
un grand coup de pied qui était en
quelque sorte la conclusion de cet
interrogatoire
lorsqu'elle sortait elle était
accompagnée par un policier ce policier
l'insulté devant la population
lorsqu'elle faisait la queue pour faire
ses provisions
aujourd'hui dont une accordé à ne semble
plus seuls d'autres voix osent s'élever
contre ce pouvoir mais il serait
surprenant que chez secoue les supporter
davantage
je vous rappelle que le 26 janvier le
magazine résistance sera donc consacrée
à l'art humaniste du dictateur ceaucescu
un régime que plus personne ne défend
hier par exemple georges marchais l'a
violemment condamné dans l'heure de
vérité
d'autres informations internationales
dans l'actualité de ce mardi
en bref en images renault gex les
français quittent le chat sur la pointe
des pieds 300 des 1300 soldats du
dispositif épervier se retire de la base
de radar de moussoro site au nord de la
capitale n'djamena principal réseau de
ce démantèlement le récent réchauffement
diplomatique entre le tchad et la libye
et la victoire en 87 des tchadiens sur
les armées de kadhafi al wadi doux
rencontre historique ce matin au vatican
entre le pape jean paul ii et le premier
ministre iranien hossein moussavi en
visite pour 48 heures en italie les deux
hommes ont évoqué un possible échange de
prisonniers de guerre contre l'irak ou
l'iran échange de cadeaux
au même moment les manifestants
anticommunistes dénoncé place saint
pierre
la guerre et la répression au pays de
l'intégrer
premier match officiel hier en italie de
l'équipe palestinienne de l'ol paie
inexpérimentés les rouges ont essuyé une
défaite façon joueur toscan dème folie
ici en bleu placé en deuxième division
le score 2 buts à 0 cette tournée
sportive et diplomatique dure qu'une
dizaine de jours les joueurs de l'ol
paie doivent prochainement se rendre et
france
scandale en italie la direction de fiat
propose de bien étranges contrat à ses
ouvriers ou plutôt de bien étranges
marchandage
oui à certains avantages oui à certaines
signatures de contrat à condition à
condition de déchirer et carte syndicale
marcel trillât notre correspondant en
italie a enquêté sur un de ces cas une
mère et un père brisé leur fils aîné joe
zep est situé en moto le 22 juillet
dernier il avait 18 ans
chaque matin au cimetière de turin ils
reviennent se heurter à l'irrémédiable
le jour de l'enterrement un cadre était
venu présenter les condoléances de la
fiat ou angelo beatles all y travaille
depuis 23 ans apporte les factures
aurait-il dit la fiat participant aux
frais il y en avait pour quarante cinq
mille francs environ
il faut préciser que moi je n'avais rien
demandé à la fia fois qu'ils ont eu les
factures après 15 ou 20 jours
mais sainte on a fait savoir qu'elle
officieux le bureau d'assistance avait
enquêté sur moi et qu'ils avaient
découvert que j'ai des inscrits aux
syndicats à la cjr
aussi il était désolé mais il ne pouvait
rien faire pour moi et nous détruit dit
un peu soulagée compris vous voulez dire
que je devrais déchiré la carte du
syndicat des magiciennes tous la paix
pourquoi pas celle du parti communiste
où je suis à ce que aussi pour avoir
l'argent venu wings alors j'ai dit non
je suis croyant j'ai dit oui en ce
moment mon fils nous et intrigante ce
qu'on peut mais mon fils tu ne serais
pas d'accord et mieux vis de nos élèves
d'accord pour faire une chose pareille
angelo butor de soli et cariste à la
carrosserie de la fiat
il gagne environ 5000 francs par mois
mais grâce aux ménages fait la nuit par
sa femme et à force d'économies
il est aujourd'hui à l'abri du besoin
c'est l'argument utilisé par la
direction pour réfuté ces accusations
n'étant pas nécessiteux il n'avait aucun
droit à cette personne ne lui a promis
c'est lui qui a fait la demande
ayant su que d'autres avaient bénéficié
de cet avantage et on lui a expliqué
qu'il n'y avait pas droit aux repas
d'après lui c'est le chef qui lui avait
promis ce remboursement sahara
oui ça bouge est un mensonge que c'est
un mensonge complet il en un mot tout au
tout pourtant d'après le ministre du
travail les premiers résultats des
enquêtes qu'il a ordonnée dans les
ateliers confirmeraient l'existence de
nombreux cas de pression anti syndicale
même si les salariés de la fiat ne se
précipite pas pour témoigner
vous avez entendu parler de cette
histoire j'ai entendu parler de rien un
ouvrier italien ne peut jamais prendre
le risque de venir devant les portes de
l'usiné et dire voilà ce qui m'est
arrivé il ne le dira jamais assez la
même chose qu'en sicile quand ils ont
assassiné quelqu'un et personne n'a
jamais rien vu c'est vrai ce qu'il dit
tout est vrai patron ses ouvriers à
chacun sa vérité
en sport les français très médiocre aux
internationaux de tennis d'australie
seul eric winogradsky s'est qualifié
pour le deuxième tour schmoove m yannick
noah faisait son retour à la compétition
après presque cinq mois d'absence et de
blessure malheureusement il était tombé
le premier tour sur l'un des âmes depuis
en forme du moment
marc coups de feu l'australien et noah a
dû s'incliner au cinquième set d'un
match très 20 ans un ski nouvelle
victoire du luxembourgeois girard
believe in dans le hall géant adelboden
il gagne devant le norvégien pour cette
élite amiens tomba troisième sherrard
délit augmente son avance en tête de la
coupe
comment s'y retrouver dans tous les
livres qui paraissent sur la révolution
déjà plus de 500 livres à l'occasion du
bicentenaire chaque commune chaque corps
de métier sort le sien alors lequel
acheter surtout quand on a tout oublié
du cours d'histoire
petite sélection sylvie marion profonde
et camille desmoulins et fabre
d'églantine
à la différence entre les massacres de
septembre et la terreur
vous savez plus ce qu'est le serment du
jeu de paume et vous est pris de tourner
ou dans les librairies qui croule sous
les livres sur la révolution française
alors inventé voodoo toute urgence une
nièce ou un filleul et procurez vous la
révolution française raconter aux
enfants déjà un best-seller auprès des
adultes
ce livre met en place tous les éléments
tous les personnages
alors et alors seulement vous pouvez
piocher dans les chronologies
après les chronologies vous serez mieux
pour les synthèses plus subtil que vous
pensez en général on sent très bien
qu'il ya deux courants de personnes pour
qui la révolution c'est avant tout le
bain de sang
incarnée par la terreur un autre courant
pour qui on sent que la révolution c'est
avant tout les grandes idées les droits
de l'homme la naissance d'un idéal
républicain
la révolution c'est la naissance de la
droite et de la gauche
si vous pensez que la révolution est
finie il faut dire les furets
si vous pensez qu'il ya encore des
bastides à prendre il faut lire les
rebelles si vous êtes une femme découvre
et les textes féminin occultée jusqu'à
nos jours sauf les révolutionnaires
discours d'aristocrates hommes des
femmes fait bovidés en famille dans la
france de 1789
et la moindre commune a mis à jour son
histoire pendant la révolution
et comme vous serez très fatigué vous
pourrez vous détendre en vente avec ou
contre les révolutionnaires
y aller d'un tiercé on va aller très
vite maintenant il y avait un tiercé
c'était à vincennes date d'arrivée 13 4
et 3 voici les rappeurs ils sont trés
groupe pour ce tiercé fin de cette
édition la météo tout de suite avec
sophie davant vers minuit henri sannier
pour la dernière édition du journal puis
n'oubliez pas télématin demain à partir
de 6h45 excellente soirée sur interne de
à demain soir 20h